right now on the phone line is the head
coach of the New Orleans Saints a super
bowl-winning head coach and more
importantly the position coach back in
the day at San Diego State of 1 Marshall
Faulk Sean Payton joining the Rich Eisen
show live on the phone how are you coach
I'm doing fine Congrats on the show it's
good to be on thanks coach appreciate it
when you first what would give me the
story when you first met Marshall coach
oh it's a true freshman I was at Indiana
State it heard all about him he had a
breakout year that true freshman season
and ended up leading the nation in
rushing and really only played I think
eight or nine of the games so I came in
for his true sophomore and junior year
so I I was the running back coach my
first year there he was a sophomore
season and and then the following year I
was coaching quarterbacks but he the one
thing about Marshall and look I say this
he's right there is great a player and
his talented he was physically he was
exceptionally exceptionally smart with
the game in there was a challenge than
just keeping him interested because he
knew certainly the basic stuff and you
know the rest of the room needed to hear
certain certain things that were
important it was it was hard keeping him
focused because all that came very easy
to him so his ability and protections
and and schemes was really way ahead of
a lot of players and I think that
carried over even in his NFL career he
was one of the smartest players on the
field now you left Marshall in a way
that it sounds like he edited that story
right there no it was well obviously he
did a little bit but the parts about it
is is is knowing like now looking back
at at the kid that I was and and just in
just how you know you just you don't
know like you don't understand sometimes
when you're sitting in the meeting room
and the coaches coaching you know they
don't coach up they coach down sometimes
and when I say down it's like what guys
don't know he's not coaching to what I
know like move forward he has to make
sure the guys behind me understand what
needs to happen if something happens to
me because it's just it's his job to
have them prepare to play as well that's
what good coaches do they don't just
rely on the guy that starting bright you
know and and and that's what it was and
and a lot of going to college
I understood offensive football and I
play defense but I didn't really
understand scheme and what people did
and and i'ma say what made my transition
from college to pro and and and even
even from from just getting to the pros
excelling in the pros was coach Pete
challenging me okay giving me the
quarterback test asking me not just like
what this offensive play is but tell me
what defense how are we going to attack
this defense whose force whose contain
through what coverage I mean it's just
so much stuff that he that he opened my
eyes to that I remember getting up on
the board at the combine talking to the
the coats and and talking to the Bengals
and I think the Giants and the Redskins
and being able to talk to him at their
level with their language it was it was
I remember him looking at me like wow
wow you remember that coach listen and I
would say I would share this with you it
became a monster the longer he played
there you would watch flips he was able
to and I'm talking about at our level at
the NFL now hey when you watch them on
the sidelines adjusting protections and
hat and having insight and input I think
that coordinators play callers trusted
certainly Mike Martz the flexibility it
gives you when you're when your runner
is able to see the very same things the
court vaccine and so you know it was
apparent that he was gifted that way
early in his career and then it was just
a matter of hey had he
keep him occupied and how'd he find a
way for him to get something wrong on a
test it's hard to do interesting
Marshall I thought the only thing you
told the Bengals was don't draft me I
did okay I thought that was the only
that was after I'm well that was after I
worked out okay and I got a chance to
meet so I wasn't Jump Street no no no it
was after coach Payton you're you're
Saints on the by week right now I'd love
for you just to generally assess them
assess your team right now as your as
your matriculating through your season
well look through five games it's easy
to see we haven't played as good as we
hope to we were able to get the win last
weekend and overtime against Tampa Bay
and I think there's a number of things
that we're going to have to do better in
order for us to have the type of season
we wanted to have I thought I thought
our ability on defense last week to stop
the run was much improved I thought guys
fit their gaps well but the the next
stretch of football we're getting ready
to play is going to be challenging and
we're gonna have to be a better and give
away take away market that's the only
reason we win last weekend - - and the
turnovers is because of the pennant
penalty differential they they were dead
157 yards negated in penalties Tampa
that is and that kind of offset the
turnover so I think there's enough stuff
for us to clean up and you know the buy
also comes at a time where a few of our
guys that are nicked up from the game we
just played can get healthy but we
haven't played as well as we hope and
we're working to fix that down hey coach
I always felt like a head coach you can
really tell who he is by by how he
handled the losses all coaches can
handle the wins how do you handle the
losses and what's the difference the
loss to Atlanta and the loss to
Cleveland they were they were kind of
similar but the loss to Dallas was just
a I mean it was a I hadn't seen that he
the team play that way under you and I
don't know how long
the difference in the tooth and that the
three law says I gets although two were
the same well I think this I think
number one which is very important
coming in on Mondays after wins or
losses is eliminating what appears to be
the noise you know often times some of
your some of your good tape work there's
all been games well we've won and we
really didn't play that well and you can
kind of get fooled into everything's
fine and there's a ton to clean up I
think the same thing can apply in a loss
you know there's some things we did well
and yet let's make sure when we walk in
the building on Monday that we're not
allowing oftentimes those people closest
to us to remove us from the problem in
other words you know if my mom were
alive she'd be saying well they need to
get you better players and then
defensive lineman's agent and girlfriend
is talking about well they need to cover
better and they need to be able to run
it so we have these people in our lives
that can actually remove us from the
problem when we're not having success
and in those same people and bless their
hearts when we're having successful
pushes closer to the reason than maybe
we should stand in so trying to be
upfront with the corrections and
recognize here's the things that are
keeping us from winning games
specifically this game and you know as a
coach you find yourself you know coming
off of wins kind of pushing for making
sure they understand hey we're not as
good as we think we are and then awful
losses look we can get this cleaned up
to be just fine
and I think that's very applicable in
these last few weeks it's certainly
coming off the Dallas game making sure
they understand look this game got away
and here's why it did now we're in a
sprint we're in a literal sprint to
improve and the team's look there's a
bunch of teams sitting two three and two
and two and three right now and it seems
that separate themselves here down the
stretch during the middle half of the
last half this season though the ones
that they're going to improve the most
from the early weeks to either plane
later in year let's talk about your
quarterback I mean I've watched and I've
been on record and and I'm saying and
I'll say it to you I said okay Drew's in
a little bit of a slump
I've seen him mr. Rose that I don't
usually see him miss what do you do well
first if you see the slump or you see
the thing that he he may be struggling
with if it's a mechanic or not what do
you do to get him back on track
well I think this I think number one
mechanically he's doing fine he's got a
great routine he's you know how his
preparation is certainly he missed some
training camp with the oblique injury
and you know it's the first time in a
while that he didn't take most of all
all the rest that he normally would have
been training camp I think the number
one thing that to ensure good
quarterback plays is playing well
defensively and running the football and
we can control the ladder in the first
part you know I think our rushing
numbers are up and yet you know he still
ended up throwing ball 57 times the
other day which is too much for my
liking and I can directly affect that
and then I think as as our defense
continues to improve
there there needs to be we need to
remove the stress that we got a school
on every possession obviously we think
that way but but I think that he's his
own toughest critic and he's going to
look closely at it some of the throws
that you're you're alluding to but I
think from a training standpoint arm
strength mechanics this this guy is
going to be fantastic as the season goes
on and and I think that hey we've got to
look closely at painting the picture
around and be at the receivers the tight
ends the backs that are out in the
routes we can't fool them with certain
things or looks that he's counting on
and all of a sudden it's a little
different I think a running game has
improved this year the numbers are way
up and we've got to continue lean on
that as well and I think that being said
all the sub plane that position becomes
a lot easier well I know I don't have a
Super Bowl ring and I would never tell
you how to do your job coach but maybe
drew needs more formula for oxygenated
water what do you think
well he's at it now it's it's been in
our building for about a year and a half
but so this group from Canada Canada
just introduced us to the product a year
ago and just this past month the test
results all came back and basically it's
a it's a water you drink it's healthy
there's no additional ingredients in it
they found a way to to increase the
amount of oxygen that goes into your
blood when you drink it and so our team
has had it now for a year and a half I
swear by it's been a difference maker
just within our training and I think
when you get into those half mile mile
workouts or twenty minutes or longer
workouts where it's a cardio burn I
think you're gonna see a result the
dramatic result well coach I know you're
you're involved with that with that
water and and I and I really appreciate
you taking your time on your bye week to
phone in and hang out with your your old
running back right here who hasn't
changed a bit by the way and he always
every time we talk about the Saints on
game day morning he talks about every
sold popcorn in the Super tell me it's a
little bit more pep in his step when he
talks about the fleur-de-lis on the side
of somebody's helmet coach I know it
does just a just kind of people avoid
showing those earlier games of footages
of our quarterbacks warming up on the
sidelines yeah we did that one Sunday
game day more I think we showed the
wrong video we showed a video of Russell
and Brees warming up from the previous
game yeah I'm supposed to be filling in
the inactive in my hotel room eating
breakfast oh so funny so you're watching
you're watching the game day morning and
and and we showed the wrong video and
you thought you'd you'd missed them
early or late bus so what happens on the
other side of the lake it's it's an hour
and 50 minutes before the game and I'm
supposed to be dressed in the locker
room get ready to meet with the
officials and I'm a half an hour away
and I'm watching the quarterbacks warmup
it was awful and we and how many how
many player we never you're late is an
awful feeling I couldn't imagine if
you're at a head coach and you had that
feeling we have the Bell thundering
nightmare oh my god the lights are on
you're in traffic two hours away in your
underwear coach thanks for joining us
appreciate it and good luck down the
road hopefully we'll see you better
that's Sean Payton